police have been using tear gas on
protesters at the prime minister's
residence but why nicole standing by for
us tell us more nicole
the situation has really deteriorated
here just in the last hour you can
see that crowds of young people are
trying to break into the prime
minister's house they have been marching
here demanding that the prime minister
resign the president is expected to
resign later today but they say that
that is not enough that they want the
prime minister gone as well
you can see the security forces are
on the gate there tear gas has been
fired and young people are trying to
break through the gates into this
building now they haven't succeeded so
far
a curfew has been imposed effective
immediately here in colombo clearly no
one here is paying any attention to that
it also applies to all the western
districts and an emergency law has been
introduced so security forces and
officials
seem to believe that the situation here
may get
even worse in other parts of the city
though protesters are continuing to
occupy
key government buildings they say that
they won't leave these buildings until
the president resigns
officially
and the prime minister goes
the president good to buy a rudger
has left the country he left on a
military jet and he's in the maldives
we're expecting that from there he'll
then go on to
[Applause]
but aside from the tear gas it hasn't
been a particularly violent protest at
all it was largely peaceful and people
had told us that they had no intention
on trying to score
just to give you a sense of what's going
on
[Applause]
so a crazy situation here in sri lanka
people are frustrated they have had
months of economic disaster there are
food and fuel cues
all over the city
whatever happens politically that's not
going to change their situation
[Applause]
now you can hear some of that firing
ongoing at the moment
the crowds aren't running let's start
moving back guys we're just going to
move out of
the way a little bit
uh so
quite unbelievable scenes here in sri
lanka we thought it would be a day more
of celebration with the news that the
president
had left the country which was one of
their major demands
but it's not enough for these people
they're so fed up with how their lives
have been
how did it end up in such an economic
disaster well they blame all of that on
the rancho pax of political dynasty and
they say that until they're all gone and
all the cronies their protests will
continue